we can't react like Lazarus we just keep
coming back we don't need to boast a
roaster talk smack a rap about women
blinging record contracts be honest be
cool and people will respect you those
are the facts dude
[Music]
you see taxis are Ubers the stars are
YouTubers Neil geising gave Pluto the ax
cell phones got smarter the ocean's got
hotter the global economy collapsed
we get internet deals on our hyphenate
meals like a tree vegan paleo sausage we
don't leave our homes thanks to Amazon
drones they track what we do through our
watches
we went away oh update us please and
foreign
[Music]
at least we think there's still a
president Trump you see the writers are
writing this in 2018. how is that
possible that people rely on anime
rights for outrageous and relevant
content well how can we finish catching
up when we don't know what happened in
the last two years I don't know wild
guesses sounds good to me we have chips
in our brains reading along to feel pain
never worsening climate disasters now we
live underground and we can't make a
sound let's
reactive
creepy Birds without arms on our factory
farms and we live in aluminum bunkers we
send humans to Mars and the top rated
show is called Clunkers it's about a
talking police car there's also a time
machine wow here comes the star
I travel through time following crime
[Music]
friends
[Applause]
we ran out of ideas for fresh Nations
show Hollywood did the only thing it
knows Murphy Brown Melrose Place Gilmore
Girls Lost in Space that's so Ravens
what they're craving I know that's a
show worth saving I vote X-Files for a
comeback the company still a real snack
with the Golden Girls be darker if we
resurrect be Arthur
[Music]
there's no need to feel frustrated
simply just regurgitate it for a
guaranteed rating
[Music]
willing Grace and Dynasty sweet 16 on
MTV Blues Clues Twin Peaks and Fargo go
catch Carmen San Diego just relax and
take the Flack if people want it bring
it back Looney Tunes queer eye and
DuckTales just reboot it cause itself
[Music]
reinstate it reheat it recreate it
there's no need to feel frustrated
simply just regurgitate it for a
guaranteed rating smash dig it up out of
the trash come on just remove it
[Music]
all right little dog monkey man let's
see what you got
[Music]
our last poor Jay Park I don't know who
you're supposed to be all the world's a
stage but player leave this stage to me
to rap or not to rap that is the
question it doesn't have to be like this
all arrogance and aggression My Boy Bill
told us Pride Comet before the fall
where you're about to take a humble
tumble else Yak a liar called
hmm
[Music]
yo if that was my sister I'd fire her
and whack was even less like a bowl than
Elmira Spielberg gotta stick to film the
Sharks now rebooting this rebooted
Groucho Marx Hulu wrote a check and the
money back in but the ones I like a bad
joke told twice if you weren't funny the
first round why would you be the second
wanna compare my 30 Grammys to your
eight Emmys
you've been put to sleep kid it's time
to say good night everybody
well that was just plain me
[Music]
nice try pal but Wacko's wishes I
deliver a killer verse I've been blasted
cursed with a bottomless little purse
that'll make crowds dispers some worse
require medical tension better get the
nurse say goodbye to an easy battleland
hello hearse
whoa
yeah
I'm training of the belly to the max
leader of the animated Maniacs you
you're the cure for insomniacs Less
fresh than the 20 year old baloney in my
slabs we can't be asked like Lazarus we
just keep coming back we don't need to
boast a roaster talk smack a rap about
women flinging record contracts be
honestly cool and people will respect
you those are the facts dude
[Music]
oh
this is silly silly very good let us
explain don't be coiled Johnny boy we
have seen what you've decreed you taxed
and pillaged every village and ignored
their every need so we wrote the Magna
Carta which is Latin for great Charter
and you do well I spoke Rebel to sign
this clever Creed the British also have
their trials and I'll tell you what's
more neither King nor son nor anyone
will be above the law so if you're to
have a hope and when the blessings of
the Pope you can't decline you'll have
to sign up they say Civil War
[Music]
United Nations declarations
if shelling out fistfuls of cash makes
you break out in a rash consider
building something on your own you'll
need some water spinning blades and
paper nails paint and first aid voila
you see you did it all for free
so if you don't mind the sawdust you can
do it yourself admire your work and just
do it yourself it might look a little
crooked but you did it yourself
self-reliant is the way to be
I'm thinking next we make some pasta
plant my blue forget me nuts the state
flower of Alaska don't you know these
store-bought girls can take a hike
they're blind land and look alike but
mine is refined it's one of a kind if
you've got enough hot glue you can do it
yourself paint over the cracks and just
do it yourself you'll make treasure out
of trash if you just do it yourself
don't worry about the hoes
this parking lot is pretty cool but not
as handy as a pool to dip our toes has
always been a dream
on our Masterpiece wow this rehab is
looking so
[Music]
and it's totally free I can sing it to
you as a song
or if a song's not to your liking I
could eat you well take the song huh
well not everybody goes for the song but
okay the ice caps they say are shrinking
away goodbye to the polar bear I know
what you're thinking the whole world is
sinking but there's no need to despair
let's burn cold boy Godzilla we're gonna
make polar the hottest postcode anywhere
soon the Arctic will be like a hundred
degrees tell me who wants to buy a
Timeshare here comes the CE here comes
the c-e-e with sea levels Rising I'm
advertising one month's rent for free
Arctic housing once was cold this
two-bedroom app will soon be sold invest
in scuba goodbye to Cuba here comes the
sea
[Music]
I know the world is getting much hotter
but this is no time for Tears fall out
the glacier's Melt then the water will
drown Us in 50 years
opinion is forming its clear global
warming is something we'll have to
embrace pollution can't keep on cause
when all the lands go we'll have to
start living in space
[Music]
can we stop pretending The World Isn't
ending and do something useful please
you see the ice reflects the sun and it
cools down everyone forget housing
bubbles we're in real troubles here
comes the sea you might have all these
chumps fooled
all right you guys are tough customers
guess I need to put a little Sizzle on
this steak oh
[Music]
when glaciers I die and everyone's
buying new Beach property location is
the Golden Rule and we've got the
world's most spacious pool did I mention
it's heated no credit needed here's your
new key the coral is bleaching please no
more preaching renters will
vanishes
[Music]
I got money back guaranteed
is that enough ketchup brain
[Music]
brain
International
Mouse of mystery he's the smartest as
Mouse in history so
drives his feet are rather blistery his
brain and his own
is always
[Music]
[Applause]